did you celebrate 23 years 23 years in
October let's let past October supposed
to get there no no my husband I had
forgotten to anniversary oh well yeah
somebody he was hunting and I was like a
sleep and they emailed us and they were
like happy anniversary we were like oh
my god like ordering flowers and I was
like calling him totally forget it fine
but what did you do to celebrate that's
gosh I was in Australia I think this is
the first anniversary we were apart yeah
but we were backstage and I recorded the
very first song that we ever did
together we did the spontaneous
combustion tour where we met when she
was opening for me on my very first
headlining tour and we used to do the
Tony rich so nobody knows but me so I
recorded that backstage with the guys
and we sent it to her oh that's cute
that was pretty cute so I just saw two
of your kids backstage but your two
oldest kids are out of the house are you
all excited about being empty nesters I
don't know if we're excited about it we
miss them Gracie and Maggie I'm gonna be
like I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this